[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kreisel
berichte und christian sievers guten
abend dass unsere erde ihr wetter und
ihr klima uns gerade ganz deutlich
zeigen wie viel da aus dem gleichgewicht
geraten ist
dieses mulmige gefühl wird immer wieder
neu bestätigt das sind bilder aus der
provinz hunan in china wo so viel und so
heftig geregnet hat wie seit jahrzehnten
nicht mehr
das problem kommt uns deutschen gerade
sehr bekannt vor in china steht eine 9
millionen metropole unter wasser der
strom fällt aus die straßen werden zu
reißenden flüssen und dann das
alptraumhafte bilder aus überfluteten u
bahn waggons nach offiziellen berichten
gab es allein hier unten zwölf tote
solche regenfälle gibt es normalerweise
nur einmal in hundert jahren die lage
ist düster sagte der lokale krisenstab
bei uns werden tief bernd und seine
folgen wohl zur teuersten
naturkatastrophe dieses jahrhunderts
schätzen die versicherungen
der staat will jetzt mit mindestens 400
millionen euro sofort helfen und
gleichzeitig ist allen klar das wird nur
der absolute anfang sein
peter böhme das rathaus von schleiden
liegt höher keine schäden aber unten
liegt nun ein autofriedhof in diesen
wagen starben menschen das wasser
stürzte meter hoch runter zum
kreisverkehr
wer nicht aus dem auto kam hatte keine
chance das flüsschen olaf nun wieder ein
pletscher bach vor einer woche dutzende
meter breit
dazu kam hangwasser was von oben runter
geströmt ist das ganze hat an einen
strudel gebildet
am kreisverkehr der extrem gefährlich
gewesen ist wegen einer reißenden
strömung und hoher wassertiefe so dass
wir da auch irgendwann keine
rettungskräfte mehr einstecken
der bürgermeister plötzlich
krisenmanager drei stunden schlaf
ansonsten auf trab schneiden in der
eifel 18 ortsteile 12.000 einwohner und
berge von müll bei andrea die freier
sieht aus wie nach einem bombenangriff
draußen trocken etwas sonst in den
kleiderschränken seiner familie hängt er
hat angst vorm nächsten regen sein
wunsch zeit zeit wo ist noch warm ist
um das ganze im trockenen noch so
hinzubekommen
an diesem supermarkt stand das wasser
bis zur roten dachkante und auf dem dach
standen kunden und angestellte nebenan
taxi unternehmer gerd faber zwölf fahrer
zwölf autos aber fünf sind kaputt da
droht fünfmal arbeitslosigkeit ja ich
musste dringend neue fahrzeuge haben
weil ich wieder alle stehen
ich habe denn jetzt eine der läuft zwar
noch aber sechs in der werkstatt 670
fehlermeldung sagt eigentlich ganz
hinter dem verschrotten geldsorgen
allerorten abgesoffene erdgeschosse
zerstörte küchen und die ungewissheit
wie soll ich das stemmen aus berlin
heute deutliche ansagen soforthilfen für
betroffene 400 millionen euro zunächst
von bund und ländern bei bedarf mehr
versprechen sie das geld soll schnell
über die länder organisiert werden und
deshalb ist es gut dass man diesen
menschen jetzt in den nächsten tagen
hilft dass dieses unbürokratisch erfolgt
das scheint mir ganz wichtig dass da
jetzt nicht große einkommens oder
vermögens überprüfungen stattfinden
sondern die hilfe schnell stattfindet
und auch zerstörte gebäude soll nun mit
staatsgeld wieder aufgebaut werden
denn jemand von einem solchen ereignis
betroffen ist dann kann ja nichts dafür
ich finde das muss man
doch ausdrücklich sagen die bürgerinnen
und bürger sind doch nicht schuld an dem
unglück dass ihnen passiert ist ja es
ist so dass dazu die mittel
bereitgestellt werden selbstverständlich
für die kaputte städtische infrastruktur
soll ein aufbau fortgebildet werden
beratungen im juli finanzrahmen noch
unklar
wir müssen gucken dass unsere
verkehrswege intakt bleiben und bei ling
dass unsere schulen und kindergärten die
massiv betroffen sind möglichst nah
wieder ans netz kommen sie sehen die
müll thematiken hier
wir müssen gucken dass das weg um das
keine infektionen aufbrechen dass die
leute nicht krank werden also geld
ausgeben können wir hier mit vollen
händen
dann blickt er auf die schuttmassen und
weiß dass die arbeit noch sehr lange
dauern wird
die großen blauen lkw und deren
besatzungen sind in den letzten tagen
überall auf deutschen autobahnen zu
sehen auf dem weg dorthin wo geholfen
und aufgeräumt werden muss sabine lakner
ist vizepräsidentin des technischen
hilfswerks einer bundesbehörde auf die
es jetzt ankommt vor ort gut am vortag
nach guten am tier sie das können sie
uns denn einen überblick geben wo stehen
sie gerade bei diesen hilfsarbeiten es
gibt ja zum beispiel immer noch
vermisste können sie da jetzt entwarnung
geben oder wird die zahl der toten
tatsächlich noch einmal deutlich steigen
das technische hilfswerk ist derzeit mit
rund 3.500 ehrenamtlichen einsatzkräften
in den schadens gebieten unterwegs das
ist natürlich prioritär
nordrhein-westfalen rheinland-pfalz aber
ich möchte auch erinnern an das
berchtesgadener land und auch an die
sächsische schweiz der sehr stark
betroffene raum ahrweiler
da haben wir leider immer noch nach
unserem kenntnisstand 155 vermisste
personen leider wir sind mittlerweile an
tag 5 schwindet ein wenig die hoffnung
dass wir in der tat menschen noch werden
retten können
wunder gibt es natürlich immer wieder
allerdings ist es bei dieser
schadenslage wir sprechen hier von
schlamm
wir sprechen von wasser das geht
natürlich in nischen aus
erdbebengebieten kennen wir dass sich
manche menschen noch in eingestürzten
gebäuden in nischen gefunden
davon ist wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
auszugehen momentan was man aber
natürlich noch hoffen könnte zumindest
ist das die sich einfach bisher nicht
gemeldet haben oder doppelt gemeldet
waren und es einfach schlicht personen
sind die tatsächlich am leben sind aber
auf der falschen liste sozusagen stehen
aktuell oder ganz ganz ganz genau ganz
genau und da drücken wir auch ganz feste
die daumen dass das für die meisten
wirklich auch noch der fall ist
vom start von bund und ländern kommen
heute 400 millionen euro an soforthilfe
das wird ja das ist vollkommen klar
nicht mal ansatzweise reichen was ist
denn aus thw sich jetzt das nötigste
dass der staat jetzt tun muss diese
soforthilfen jetzt mal aus perspektive
gesprochen eines betroffenen bürgers
oder einer bürgerin
das ist ganz klar dass hilfe jetzt
direkt bei den menschen ankommt für uns
als hilfsorganisation als die
bevölkerungsschutz organisation des
bundes ist es auch ganz wichtig dass wir
mit den mitteln mit dem wir schon sehr
gut ausgestattet sind dass wir da weiter
vorangehen beispiel das handy system
telefon kommunikation ist ausgefallen
hier brauchen wir künftig auch weitere
redundanzen wir konnten uns jetzt
behelfen mit satellitentelefonen wir
müssen da auch weitergehen und redundant
aufstellen damit auch die kommunikation
einmal unter den einsatzkräften zur
koordinierung der hilfe leistung auch
weiter aufrechterhalten werden kann
jetzt haben sie mitbekommen es läuft ja
im moment bereits eine große diskussion
über die warnungen rechtzeitige
warnungen weil das ja aktuell an vielen
orten offenbar schlecht beziehungsweise
gar nicht lief was ist denn ihre
empfehlung aus dieser katastrophe jetzt
sirenen sms für alle in einem bestimmten
gebiet lautsprecherwagen vor ort was
wäre ihre idee alles wir brauchen den
gesamten mix an möglichkeiten
denn wenn wir zum beispiel das thema
cell broadcast in haben wenn kein handy
kein telefon kein internet funktioniert
kann ich auch auf keinem vanek schauen
also es haben warnungen durchaus
funktioniert wir dürfen uns nur nicht
auf die hochspezialisierten dinge allein
lassen wir brauchen den gesamten mix der
möglichkeiten also alles ja sie weiß was
sie gerade aufgezählt haben jetzt kommt
auch von ihnen also aus dem thw von
helferinnen und helfern
doch einiges an kritik auch auf die
einsatzstelle die krisenstäbe vor ort zu
design heillos überfordert gewesen man
hört zum beispiel von einem thw
zugführer der mit 18 fahrzeugen 13 boten
67 helfern unterwegs war und nach
stundenlanger anfahrt dann sofort wieder
nach hause geschickt wurde
wie kann denn sowas sein ich möchte
zunächst daran erinnern dass bei jeder
katastrophe wir haben immer eine
chaosphase das ist im moment das wird
man nie beseitigen
dann möchte ich auch in erinnerung
gerufen dass entscheidungsträgerinnen
und entscheidungsträger vor ort das ist
der bürgermeister bürgermeisterin
landrat landrätin selbst betroffen war
auch wir beim thw
der ortsverband der ehrenamtliche
ortsverband ahrweiler ist überflutet
worden
ehrenamtliche kräfte haben ihre
privatfahrzeuge mit denen sie zum
unterkunft gefahren sind verloren und
unter dieser voraussetzung immer noch zu
funktionieren
und da möchte ich auch mal sagen
hochachtung dass menschen gesagt haben
auch wenn bei mir zum beispiel das haus
abgesoffen ist ich weiß meine lieben in
sicherheit ich gehe jetzt und mache
meinen job
das möchte ich an der stelle wirklich
nochmal vorausschicken es ist so dass
wir uns auch koordinieren mussten das
läuft mittlerweile deutlich besser ich
möchte nicht sagen dass es nicht auch
fehler gegeben hat das bessere ist
bekanntlich feind des guten und von
daher daraus lernen wir merken jetzt es
läuft deutlich koordinierter artmann hat
sich gefunden wird zum beispiel als thw
entsenden
sehr viel fachberatung in einzelne stäbe
um auch zu zeigen um zu sagen das können
wir hier können wir hilfe leisten also
viele lektionen aus dieser katastrophe
für das thw für uns alle natürlich auch
sabine lacma die vize-präsidentin des
technischen hilfswerks vielen dank das
gespräch haben wir ganz kurz vor der
sendung aufgezeichnet den klimaschutz
haben jetzt fast alle politiker für sich
entdeckt als gesellschaftliches ziel
und als wahlkampfthema manche von ihnen
mehr oder weniger plötzlich und andere
gleich mit einem griffigen schlagwort
womit wir bei markus söder während der
heute für bayern den klima rock ausrief
und damit bei der eigenen
schwesterpartei cdu schon mal genervtes
augenrollen auslöste und bei der
opposition die forderung er müsse
liefern und nicht nur ankündigen aus
münchen stefan leifert die erinnerung
daran dass die pegel der flüsse aus den
fugen sind fließt mit der iza-direktor
münchner landtag vorbei dort tritt heute
ein ministerpräsident auf der nach dem
hochwasser zum ganz grossen klima
rundumschlag ausholt eine
regierungserklärung als politisches echo
auf die katastrophe der letzten tage wir
stehen davon bin ich fest überzeugt und
es ist belegt wissenschaftlich an der
schwelle epochaler veränderungen
entweder wir verstehen ist und handeln
wurde wir werden mit dramatischen folgen
langfristig konfrontieren mit den
bayrischen klimagesetz will söder
deutschland und eu beim klimaziel
überholen verspricht klimaneutralität
bis 2040 die co2 emissionen sollen bis
2030 um 65 prozent sinken maßnahmen die
sich bayern 22 milliarden euro kosten
lassen will
söder will das klima momentum nutzen
stellt sich an die spitze einer union
der solche töne nicht alle beklatschen
es ist einfach notwendig dass wir uns
der verantwortung stellen bis holt uns
sonst ein wir alle müssen ein stück weit
aus der komfortzone heraus
schröder lässt den großen klima pathos
ein kleinteiliges maßnahmenbündel folgen
eine solardach pflicht aber soll es
nicht geben auch der ausbau der
windenergie stock den bayern zu groß die
widerstände auch in söders eigenen
reihen die opposition traut ihm nicht
söder ist einer der nach überschriften
politik macht wenn das thema gerade
medial interessant ist gibt es eine
regierungserklärung dann wird
angekündigt wenn das thema aus den
schlagzeilen verschwindet dann ist das
thema auch wieder weg er macht viele
ankündigungen ersatz ziele
allerdings muss man ganz ehrlich sagen
bayern hat seit 15 jahren keinerlei
fortschritte erzielt beim klimaschutz
die treibhaus emissionen sind sogar
gestiegen
söder weiß diese flut setzt deutschlands
politiker und kandidaten unter besondere
beobachtung ein moment ähnlich wie
fukushima die flutkatastrophe ist eine
stunde der wahrheit
es richtet sich jetzt der augenmerk auf
die ernsthaftigkeit politische akteure
in sachen klimaschutz
klimaschutz ist die zukunft aufgabe
unserer generation doch so dass
wandlungen zum klimaretter nerven in der
union viele auch mit seinem vorpreschen
heute hat er ärger bei der cdu entfacht
die forderung trotz kohlekompromiss noch
schneller als vereinbart aus der kohle
auszusteigen stößt dort auf heftigen
widerspruch
es ist enttäuschend wir haben diesen
kompromiss geschlossen um ökonomie und
ökologie zusammenzubringen zu versöhnen
viele haben dazu einen beitrag geleistet
das entscheidende ist bei einem
kompromiss dass man dann auch dazu steht
es ist mächtig bewegung in deutschlands
klimapolitik war ja trifft auf
flutkatastrophe das münchen dabei nur
nebenschauplatz ist kann man seit heute
nicht mehr behaupten was bei uns nicht
funktioniert wie unvorbereitet wir sind
in diesem land das so viel gibt auf sein
organisationstalent
das haben ja jetzt gleich mehrere
katastrophen gezeigt heute ein schritt
um etwas zu ändern für die zukunft kein
server hat mir ja die bundesregierung
will eine nationale reserve für
gesundheits güter anlegen für künftige
notsituationen sollen bestimmte
medikamente eingelagert werden ebenso
wie schutzkleidung und mehr als eine
milliarde masken laut
gesundheitsminister sparen soll die
reserven für ein halbes jahr ausreichen
als weitere konsequenz aus der korona
pandemie will sich der bund
produktionskapazitäten für impfstoffe
sichern
mit blick auf die aktuelle pandemie hat
die bundesregierung die einreise regeln
verlängert bis zum 10 september
allerdings gibt es änderungen für
geimpfte sie können künftig ihre
quarantäne auch dann vorzeitig beenden
wenn sie aus einem virus varianten
gebiet kommen
voraussetzung ist dass ihre impfungen
gegen die dortige mutation wirksam ist
in frankreich liegt die sieben tage
incidence bei über 100 und die
infektionszahlen steigen rasant deshalb
wurden dort die korona regeln wieder
verschärft so muss man auf dem pariser
eiffelturm eine vollständige impfung
genesung oder einen negativ test
nachweisen
das gleiche gilt in kinos und museen
präsident marco plant eine ausweitung
dieser regel auf restaurants und
fernzüge was experten schon länger
befürchten hat das statistische
bundesamt nun bestätigt die zahl der
kindeswohlgefährdungen ist während der
korona pandemie auf einen höchststand
gestiegen
2020 verzeichneten deutschlands
jugendämter fast 60.000 600 fälle und
damit neun prozent mehr als im vorjahr
58 prozent der betroffenen kinder
zeigten zeichen von vernachlässigung bei
rund einem drittel gab es hinweise auf
psychische und bei einem viertel auf
körperliche misshandlungen in fünf
prozent der fälle gab es anzeichen für
sexuelle gewalt der streit zwischen der
eu und großbritannien über das so
genannte nordirland protokoll spitzt
sich zu london hat gefordert das
abkommen auszusetzen und neue zoll
regelungen zu verhandeln
aus brüssel kam umgehend eine absage
einer neuverhandlung werde man nicht
zustimmen dass nordirland protokoll
sieht vor dass die britische provinz
weiterhin den regeln des eu
binnenmarktes folgt die zollkontrollen
finden derzeit nicht zwischen nordirland
und irland statt sondern zwischen
nordirland und den rest des vereinigten
königreichs die eu hat ja ein
vertragsverletzungsverfahren gegen
ungarn eingeleitet wegen des lgbt kyu
gesetzes nun hat ministerpräsident orban
reagiert der könig der ein referendum
über das umstrittene gesetz an die
bürger sollen darin mehrere fragen
beantworten unter anderem ob kindern
medienberichte zugänglich sein sollen
die ihre sexuelle entwicklung
beeinflussen können
gegen das gesetz hatte es heftige
proteste gegeben es verbietet zum
beispiel bücher die homo- oder
transsexualität als teil der normalität
darstellen
und dann heute abend die folgende
nachricht und die hat es in sich
auf den ersten blick betrifft sie
schlicht eine pipeline für erdgas
tatsächlich aber ist nord stream zwei
eine geschichte bei der es um knallharte
interessen geht um politischen druck und
um milliardensummen politik mit harten
bandagen der konflikt schwelt seit
jahren
jetzt gibt es einen kompromiss zwischen
deutschland und den usa
die hatten sorge dass sich mit dieser
pipeline von russland nach mecklenburg
vorpommern deutschland und europa zu
sehr abhängig machen von russischen
energielieferungen dass die ukraine als
transitland abgeschnitten werde
ein streit mit weltpolitischen
dimensionen bei dessen lösung es
verlierer geben könnte auch wenn sich
alle seiten jetzt als sieger sehen
andreas kienast mit den details dafür
dass es drei us-präsidenten waren die
nord stream 2 verhindern wollten zehn
jahre streit sanktionen und
sanktionsdrohungen kommt die versöhnung
ziemlich unspektakulär nur eine
schriftliche mitteilung der
bundesregierung informiert vor gut einer
stunde berlin und nur ein mittel
bekannter diplomat des
us-außenministeriums informiert am
nachmittag warschau und kiew was wir
verhindert haben ist der schlimmste fall
einen ort team zwei pipeline gegen die
wir lange waren gegen die präsident
beiden schon als vizepräsident war die
fertig gestellt ist und gas
transportiert ohne ausgleich für die
ukraine und mit einer transatlantischen
partnerschaft in aufruhr
zuletzt war es noch eine glaubensfrage
die zwischen deutschland und den usa
stand kann man präsident putin glauben
es waren deutschland und die eu die
russland ab verhandelt haben dass es
noch über jahre gas durch die ukraine
transportieren wird aber die usa glauben
putin nicht und verlangen einen
pipelines not aus schalter für den fall
der fälle
merkel verspricht vergangene woche sich
etwas einfallen zu lassen
nur sagen dass wir gerade auch unsere
fachbeamten ja darüber sprechen welche
möglichkeiten der reaktion wir haben wir
werden dann sind da auch mit unseren
europäischen freunden im gespräch aber
das wird sich dann zum entscheidenden
zeitpunkt ausstellen von dem ich hoffe
dass er nicht kommt das ist nie dazu
kommt dass russland den gas transit
durch die ukraine stoppt für kiew
überlebenswichtig die ukraine fürchtet
dass russland den konflikt militärisch
eskaliert falls es nicht mehr auf seine
gasleitungen rücksicht nehmen muss falls
russland in ungerechtfertigter art und
weise druck auf die ukraine ausüben
sollte
falls russland sich an die
stabilisierungsversuche beteiligen
sollte das ist nicht akzeptabel und das
würden wir auch nicht hinnehmen
deutschland wird mit russland verhandeln
um den gastransit durch die ukraine für
das nächste jahrzehnt zu verlängern wird
das land bei der produktion von
wasserstoff fördern und notfalls
sanktionen gegen russland unterstützen
sanktionen so soll es merkel putin am
abend telefonisch mitgeteilt haben für
den fall dass russland die ukraine doch
vom gas transit trend es ist wichtig zu
sagen dass nach allem was ich bisher
weiß diese möglichkeit bei einer
politischen erpressung der ukraine die
pipeline abzuschalten für mich
windelweich erscheinen tatsächlich ist
beiden merkel weit entgegengekommen
weiter als merkel ihm die republikaner
im kongress und die vorgängerregierung
sind außer sich
dieser deal untergräbt die ukraine polen
die usa die nato jetzt bekommen die
russen enormen einfluss auf deutschlands
energieversorgung
politisch steht nord stream 2 nichts
mehr im weg technisch nur noch wenig
bereits ende august soll die
umstrittenste pipeline der welt fertig
sein und unter anderem dazu hat wulf
schmiese nachher fragen an den
bundeswirtschaftsminister im
heute-journal update so jetzt nochmal
hier keine server mit nachrichten aus
der wirtschaft der bundesgerichtshof hat
sich heute mit dem abgas skandal bei vw
beschäftigt dabei ging es um die frage
ob käufer eines betroffenen neuwagens
ein recht auf ein neuwertiges
ersatzfahrzeug haben
nun haben die richter entschieden
einen austausch wagen zu bekommen müssen
die käufer ihren anspruch innerhalb von
zwei jahren nach vertragsabschluss
geltend machen
sonst müssen sie sich mit einem
software-update begnügen
noch ist nicht abzusehen was die
flutkatastrophe am ende kosten wird aber
schon jetzt sprechen die versicherer von
der teuersten naturkatastrophe in
deutschland des jahrtausends für viele
schäden werden die steuerzahler
aufkommen müssen auch weil viele
betroffene nicht versichert waren
deshalb wird jetzt über eine
pflichtversicherung diskutiert eine
forderung sina mainitz an der
frankfurter börse die durchaus
umstritten ist ja so ist es zu diesem
thema gibt es in den vergangenen tagen
tatsächlich viel pro und contra wenig
verwunderlich denn die jetzige flut hast
du es eben gesagt gilt ja als größter
versicherungsfall in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik derzeit wird mit schäden
von rund fünf milliarden euro gerechnet
doch nur knapp die hälfte der
bevölkerung ist gegen elementarschäden
versichert die normale hausrat und
gebäudeversicherung reicht bei
hochwasser nicht aus nun gibt es eine
debatte über das für und wider einer
versicherungspflicht monika schnitzer
mitglied der wirtschaftsweisen begrüßt
diesen vorstoß wenn man verhindern will
dass manche auf eine solche versicherung
verzichten im vertrauen darauf im
katastrophenfall hilfe durch den staat
zu erhalten
dagegen spricht sich die
versicherungsbranche allen voran jörg
asmussen aus eine pflichtversicherung
kann am ende nicht die folgen der
fehlenden klima folge anpassung
schultern eine pflichtversicherung würde
auf der einen seite natürlich für eine
erhebliche erhöhung der
versicherungsdichte sorgen so dass im
wesentlichen alle häuser abgesichert
werden auf der anderen seite ist
natürlich eine pflichtversicherung ein
erheblicher eingriff in grundrechte
und das muss gut begründet werden ja die
verbraucherschützer sehen also auch vor
und nachteile
egal wie diese diskussion am ende
ausgeht die prämien dürften steigen und
diese diskussion wie häuser in
gewässernähe künftig überhaupt
versichert werden
die ist in vollem gange danke senat die
olympischen sommerspiele 2000 32 finden
in brisbane stadt das hat das
internationale olympische komitee
entschieden
die stadt im osten von australien
feierte den zuschlag mit einem feuerwerk
viele einwohner hatten sich
hoffnungsvoll auf den strassen
versammelt
für den rest der welt geht es erstmal um
die aktuellen sommerspiele die beginnen
ja offiziell übermorgen aber die ersten
sportlerinnen habe schon heute begonnen
und dabei gleich ein zeichen gesetzt
mit dem anti rassismus kniefall nun auch
vom ioc geduldet beginnt heute schon das
olympische fußballturnier und wie denn
die schwedin narren nicht nur in dieser
szene das us-team und besiegeln durch
den herrlichen lauf von hanna glas
bayern münchen und den kopfball von nina
hortig zum 13 0 ihren
überraschungserfolg gegen die
weltmeisterin
deren star megan rapinoe als
einwechselspielerin auch nichts an der
deftigen niederlage ändert martha
dagegen weltbesten fußballerin aus
brasilien gewohnt treffsicher
beim 5 0 erfolg gegen china der
präsident des deutschen olympischen
sportbundes äußert sich zwei tage vor
beginn der spiele optimistisch die
vorfreude in unserem team wächst von tag
zu tag und wir hoffen dass von diesen
spielen ein weltweit sehr positives
signal für den sport und vom sport
ausgeht die botschaft des britischen
teams aus angst vor corona werden nur 30
der 376 athleten bei der eröffnungsfeier
einmarschieren
kurz noch die lottozahlen wie immer ohne
gewähr
78 18 38 39 48 super zeit zwei weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 55 7 so und
gleich nach uns nehmen wir sie mit in
ein land in dem es gerade um alles geht
in afghanistan rücken auf der einen
seite die taliban vor
auf der anderen seite all die
afghaninnen und afghanen die für ein
freies modernes land einstehen junge
weltoffene frauen und männer die sich
nicht den selbst ernannten
gotteskriegern unterwerfen wollen
katrin eigendorf und mesa sie jetzt
gleich in der auslandsjournal doku die
rückkehr der taliban wohin steuert
afghanistan
das ist die sie jetzt vielleicht schon
kurz gemerkt haben
sehenswert vom heute schon mit ihm an
diesem mittwoch danke fürs interesse und
diesmal
[Musik]
guten abend das tief das jetzt kommt ist
ein ganz anderes kaliber als das tief
bert dieses neue tief nämlich zieht
relativ schnell vom atlantik weiter in
richtung dänemark
es bringt zwar feuchte und gewittrige
luft mit aber es sieht so schnell über
uns hinweg dass die gewitter nur
punktuell kräftigen regen bringen können
das schauen wir uns gleich genauer an
jetzt schauen wir in die nacht da gibt
es nämlich wenige wolkenfelder in
norddeutschland und im süden ist es
häufig klar
die temperaturen sinken auf 15 grad
besonders an der see und bis 9 grad in
den östlichen mittelgebirgen und steigen
morgen über tag an der küste kaum an
die tageshöchstwerte liegen bei 19 bis
21 grad sonst sind es in norddeutschland
so 20 bis 24 südlich von mosel und main
aber 25 bis 28 grad
das wetter kennen wir schon das ist ganz
ähnlich wie heute in norddeutschland
sind viele wolken unterwegs nachmittags
kommt die sonne häufiger zum zuge und
ganz vereinzelt kann es mal ein bisschen
nieselregen geben in süddeutschland gibt
es deutlich mehr sonne allerdings könnte
sich dann morgen vielleicht über der
schwäbischen alb oder auch schwarz weil
am nachmittag mal ein kleiner schauer
bilden
an diesem wetter ändert sich auch am
freitag nicht aber dann am samstag da
kommen dann die schauer und gewitter von
westen heran
sie können nordrhein-westfalen treffen
ruhe hindern pfalz das saarland das
westliche hessen und auch baden
württemberg und im laufe des sonntags
ziehen diese schauer und gewitter weiter
und wie sie hier am temperaturen und
wettertrend für köln sehen können geht
es danach wechselhafte weiter es bleibt
aber waren
guten abend